this is the position your POI briefly
moves
through while doing these wraps
slide up the tether pinch wrap once
before moving to the other side unrap
and move back down to the handle slide
up pinch wrap move to the other side of
the body
unwrap slide up pinch wrap move to the
other side of the body
unwrap slide up pinch wrap one Gra
[Music]
[Applause]
a
[Music]
slide up pinch wrap move to the other
side of the body unwrap
[Music]
don't
get
[Music]
big you
something
missing and here is the other
version this is the position your PO
briefly moves
through slide up the tether pinch wrap
once before moving to the other side
unwrap and back down to the Hamer
slide up pinch wrap
[Music]
unwrap you
now you
first goone
oh now that you
feel you
[Music]
don't get off the
[Applause]
[Music]
do out
he
n
[Music]